you know it's a scene that somehow isn't
shocking or even mildly surprising
anymore like so many other things in our
culture today what would have been
totally unimaginable just a few years
ago is now totally commonplace latest
example is footage which went viral
yesterday of elementary aged students in
a forced gay pride march through the
hallways of a school now i say this was
a forced march because it's an activity
the school came up with
i'm not sure whether the kids were
allowed to decline participation or not
but even if they were when you're a
small child in the kind of school that
holds gay pride marches in the hallway
even if you're allowed to not
participate you aren't really allowed to
not participate so here's the video
which was proudly posted by an
administrator and then quickly removed
not as proudly but let's watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right so you see all the kids uh
cycling through there
and these are all these are very young
kids as well that we see
walking down the hallway some of them
seem enthusiastic others not so much but
they're all in the march in the gay
pride march in the hallways of a school
in elementary school and this happened
by the way not in like oregon or
california or vermont or one of those
crazy leftist states but actually texas
dolls elementary school in texas um in
fact is holding a whole week of gay
celebration it's their pride week this
week they call it and it includes many
activities besides the creepy parade you
just saw there
part of the festivities are things that
the school calls community circles in
which the children will participate in
conversations that as the instructions
make clear
must remain confidential students are
told explicitly that quote what we say
in this room stays in this room
and quote remember to keep what happened
in the circle confidential and um to
make it even creepier the you know
capital t capital c for the circle it's
the circle
now if the phrase remember to keep what
happened in the circle confidential
sounds like something you'd be told at a
cult meeting and if what we say in this
room stays in this room sounds like
something that a threat sounds like
maybe like a threat from a pedophile
abuser then you're starting to
understand what our public school system
is and what it's all about
the washington examiner did reach out to
dos elementary to ask about these
secret circles and this is what they
were told quote
a spokesperson for the austin
independent school district told the
washington examiner the school the
circles were confidential in the sense
that makes students feel trusted and
respected for their privacy when sharing
in the conversations and that it should
not be misconstrued to mean don't tell
your parents
circles are part of social emotional
learning and are used for a variety of
speaking topics such as test anxiety
world events internal conflict
resolution social justice the
spokesperson said and the conversation
template allows for a process and gives
everyone an option an optional
opportunity to speak everyone not just
parents has access to the materials
ahead of time every parent has the right
to opt out of these activities
oh they give you the old opt out like
once again that's that's like opting out
of the gay pride march when you're you
know a seven-year-old at one of these
schools
yeah you could you could technically opt
out but there's a lot of social
authorization that comes with that and
also they're making it clear implicitly
and probably explicitly that if you're
not participating in all this kind of
stuff then uh you're a bigot
so now this would what you just heard
there would already be a dubious excuse
even if you were predisposed to trust
what schools tell you
but if you've been paying attention at
all you do not trust the schools at all
and so the assurances they give about
their secret gay pride circle meetings
will mean nothing to you at all
and it should mean anything to you
because the schools are just as they
appear and so often act
abusive cult indoctrination centers
they are what you might call alternative
reality generators now i've said before
that the news media are i would dub them
reality curators so they take little
bits of what's happening in the world
they cut out the parts they don't want
you to see
and they and oftentimes they will ban
you from talking about those things they
don't want you to see like what happened
with the new york post and hunter
biden's laptop and all the parts they
want you to see they assemble them into
the picture that they they want to
present to you um they operate according
to a kind of
ideologically driven algorithm and when
you're listening to the news media
that's really what you're what you're
getting that you're getting an algorithm
the actual algorithms on social media
are also ideologically driven of course
in order to skew your perception of the
world in reality itself
the schools though because they get the
kids at such a young age and have them
for so long
with hours every day of uninterrupted
indoctrination opportunities they go
even deeper they create an entire
alternate reality and after years of
that you end up with the sorts of
college kids that i encounter many of us
have seen protesting and so on
who seem like you know they're from some
sort of uh
other dimension really they seem like
beings from another dimension
they live in a world that has almost no
connection to the real world
that's why the left gets away with
propaganda campaigns that are so
blatantly false as to at first seem
almost farcical
for example yesterday kim mangione who's
a
failed politician in california
tweeted a picture of a billboard with
the word gay on it that's all it says
just says gay
and she captioned the the tweet how many
of these billboards do you want me to
put up uh in florida it's just some you
know just just as gay it's all says this
is obviously supposed to be in protest
of the so-called don't say gay bill now
my suggestion is that she put up one
billboard
for every time the word gay appears in
the legislation itself which of course
means she's not gonna be putting up any
billboards at all
because the word is not in the
legislation
but the fact that the word doesn't
appear in the legislation itself and
that the don't say gay bill is a total
fabrication of the left
doesn't matter
their strategy is very simple
they don't like the florida parental
rights bill but they can't argue against
it without sounding like a bunch of
perverted freaks so instead they
completely invent a different bill out
of thin air
and argue against that instead
they get away with it
you know
more than get away with in fact they
often win with this exact strategy
because they run all the institutions
and because
they keep society supplied with a
never-ending stream of people whose
minds and souls exist in a fictional
universe a universe the left creates now
the good news i guess
in a way
is that the people in charge of this
indoctrination are very stupid
um as the left increasingly prioritizes
ideological conformity over anything
else also the quality of what they
produce has gone down and the quality of
the people who are in charge of the
indoctrination has gone down this is why
most hollywood movies these days
are so terrible um hollywood of course
has been liberal for a long time but it
used to
you know used to hire the most talented
people to tell compelling stories and
the stories would often happen to have a
liberal bent because that was the world
view of the people telling the stories
now they don't hire the most talented
people their first second and third
priority is to fill their diversity
quotas and make films and shows that
advertise their leftist purity
this means that what they make is more
intensely ideological than it's ever
been but also that the quality is worse
than it's ever been
the bright side of that is that the
indoctrination is less effective
the more that the indoctrination is the
primary goal
christian movies on the other end of the
spectrum have long had this exact same
problem now their message is actually
good so that's the key difference and
it's an important difference
but all the films you know in the
christian movie industry care about is
the message they don't care about
telling good stories or telling them
well or having a good script good acting
it's like they consider all that to be
secondary
and so they are far less effective at
getting their message across because the
movies are bad
now
we see something like this in the school
too where many of the people teaching
our kids um
are indoctrinators and groomers of
course and also extremely stupid
case in point two middle school
counselors in oregon uh were mad this
week that they couldn't fly their gay
pride and blm flags in school
so they recorded this tick tock video in
their counseling office
in uh in protest watch
[Music]
[Music]
okay now you have to appreciate these
two ladies flipping off the camera in
front of a flag that says be kind to all
uh you also have to appreciate the
caption on the video which misspells the
word allowed and somehow that manages to
be you know the most outrageous aspect
of that video there
these are very dumb people with no
discernible skills or abilities and
double-digit iqs at best
um many such cases in the school system
but they don't need to be effective
indoctrinators really
because unlike hollywood and media and
all the other institutions
who are
less effective in indoctrination when
their quality goes down
in this case the school system they have
your kids
for so many years and so many hours in a
day that it becomes a sort of war of
attrition with your child's soul with
your child's mind
they just keep pushing until they wear
their victims down and have them firmly
in their clutches
but
there is a kind of easy solution if not
easy than at least simple which is get
your kids out of the system
and keep them up
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated